alongside me here this morning Nick it's
on a Sun shadow security minister and
shadow solicitor general good morning
resume and say today is the big day
where Theresa May will have her bricks
of a draw agreement to base it there's a
bit of a hold up because the government
are being held in contempt of Poland
that will be debated first what do you
want the results of that debate to be
today most important thing for us is
actually to have disclosed to members of
parliament the full legal advice on the
legal implications of the withdrawal
agreement it's something that Parliament
unanimously passed a motion for on 13th
of November some time ago now if it had
been disclosed as it should have been
some time ago there would be no need for
a delay today and what that will do is
allow parliamentarians and these crucial
five days of debate to make a decision
on the meaningful vote next week with
the fullest possible information okay so
at the end of today's debate will the
government publish that advice in full
is that gonna be the end result all of
this if if the debate the vote rather is
one today our motion is very clear yes
it is about ministers in contempt
apology because that's the procedure we
have to use in order to enforce the will
of the House of Commons from the 13th of
November but our motion is very clear
that the legal advice should be
disclosed immediately and that's
absolutely what we're trying to do 6
which statement did you actually make it
happen because you can have this debate
today and it's delaying the debate that
everyone wants which is about the brexit
withdraw agreement can you actually get
the government to give you that full
advice you're going through this motion
will it results in the public a perfect
publication of that for legal advice
it's because that's what the motion says
and makes very clear and it's very very
important in six different political
parties came together yesterday to write
to the speaker about this we
shouldn't be in this position the
government didn't even muster one vote
against this on the 13th of November
they should have disposed this advice
already and even at this late stage I
urge them to do so disclose that advice
give MP's the fullest possible
information and then we can move on with
the debate if they found in contempt of
Parliament what do you think the
punishment should be well if that
happens then they will be referral to
the standards and privileges committee
and they would be able to decide who is
to receive a sanction and what the
nature of that might be whether that
suspension or something else but for me
the most important issue is that advice
this is the procedure we have to use to
get it let's get hold of that advice and
make the best possible decision that's
why is it so important for labour to see
that legal advice in full because let's
face it you could see it and you're
still going to vote against Teresa Mays
deal we can obviously make a political
judgment and of course that is what I'm
here as a parliamentarian to do on the
information that's performing but there
are aspects that the government simply
hasn't given us at the moment about the
legal position and let me just give you
one example I asked the Attorney General
yesterday about the situation that is
very clear in the withdrawal agreement
but even in the event that the
government did negotiate a trade deal
parts of the so called not normal and
backstop can still come into operation
so it isn't the case that the north
Irish backstop could be only wholly
replaced by a trade agreement it could
be partly replaced I said quite simply
yesterday for the Attorney General if
that is the case it can be partly
replaced that's what the document says
you tell me which aspects of the backs
that were most likely to become
permanent in that situation a huge
question for economic future or
political future might not have the
answer to yet though because this is
obviously the withdrawal agreement the
future of the relationship between the
EU and the UK is yet to be negotiated so
they mine either no no no no what I'm
referring to is in the withdrawal
agreement which is legally binding
so the point I'm making is that they
would have to be some advice as to what
the legal implications are of that
provision like I just mentioned and that
is just what an example of something
that I've asked a question about that
I've looked at the so-called legal
commentary that's been published
obviously listen carefully to the
statement from the Attorney General
yesterday and that's just one thing that
hasn't been answered it's why it's so
important we see the full implications
of what Parliament is being asked to
sign up to next Tuesday would there be
anything in there when it's published
that would make labor change their mind
on how they're gonna vote on teresa's
Mays deal because you know some people
are thinking that labor playing politics
with this it's frustrating the process
because whatever is in that legal
document as a party you have made up
your mind to vote against Theresa Mayes
deal come hell or high water well we're
not frustrating the process because this
motion went through part of the 13th of
November the government could have
complied with it long ago and should
have complied with it long ago in
addition to that it isn't just about the
Labor Party 6 political parties were
signatories to that letter to the
Speaker of the House of Commons
yesterday this is about Parliament and
power want to see the fullest possible
information why on earth on the most
significant constitutional political
economic decision of decades shouldn't
MPs be able to see the fullest
information to make the best informed
decision we possibly can